The answer's $107.80.
So if you got it right, well done. Let's see how we got 107.80. I have a
computer monitor, and the original price was $154. And, since the computer
monitor is on sale, we know that we have to subtract the 30% from 100%, since it
is decreasing the price, since it's on sale. So we have 154 times 100% minus
30%. Well 100 minus 30 gives us 70%. Once again, whenever we use a percent in a
problem, we have to convert it to a decimal. So, 70 percent is written as .7 as
a decimal. We need to move the decimal place two places to the left. So, we have
154 &gt;&gt; Times .7.
When you multiply 154 times .7, we get 107.8. Now, this answer doesn't exactly
like what we put in the box, because we're talking in dollars and cents. 107.8
in dollars is one hundred and seven dollars and eighty cents. Once again,
remember to put the dollar sign, because it's a word problem and we need to
include the units.